hello and welcome to this video playing
Iggy Rock let's do something else play
the King alien that often the se5 was an
interesting option to potentially
transpose into a peroxy bind if you
cancelled and he just canceled and he
did so quite quickly so maybe actually
has a concrete plan IAM in the middle he
might just play every move quickly no
matter if he knows it or not
now here Bishop III is the most common
you can put the Bishop sorry you can put
the knight back already here 92 but that
is not considered that critical after 97
when White has to deal with this idea of
Bishop takes c3 layer is taken some time
so most likely it's not an opening that
he has studied extensively
so quite surprising
I mean Bishop III is a very natural
looking even if you have never seen it
no yet and find the book first to look
it up
yeah here the main choices between 92
and 2222 being the overwhelming mainline
Knights Twila is also quite good and a
move that I consider to be a bit more
critical it's what I play myself on of
course white authors are the options
like look C 1 or F three-year course not
played Knight B 3 in this position it's
also a decent idea sorry specific Duke C
1 of course is possible
I'm preparing the regrouping a 597 I
wanted before the Mafia but and think
against that I can play Bishop h6 we
should have three as uncommon yes again
5x normal 497 Yin immediately 90 70 can
take played before that I don't like now
if I can take a 320 X 97 I think it's
something similar I had on the board in
an earlier game earlier rapid game here
on replace almost the same stuff a4 is
the same strategically dubious move that
this other person played interesting
yeah I put some lots of pawns on light
squares and then there are three bishop
is potentially bad
here you can actually retreat to e3 in
that other game and that option wasn't
even available for white of course you
can also allow me to take on deform and
play em that same lucky one or something
okay so he goes back in ninety five is
the most obvious move and let's do it it
fits the square for the night anyway so
he has to worry at least a little bit
about potential capture on c3 and then
grab pawns that is actually an idea
efore is attacked there's also some
pressure on a form
chan-hom to see cover that looks
difficult to cover it with something
with something natural-looking
yeah okay I'm not going to spend ages
now to think about what is going to play
out that it's really not comfortable I
mean you can play b3n just gamble that
I'm not going to take to take you 694 I
don't know it's a big center pawn lots
um yeah this is kind of the move that
you play if you are really really
concerned about material material
strategically speaking this is a
suicidal decision giving me a fantastic
Bishop I mean okay the bishop is one
thing the other problem is that his
Bishop on c3 as a complete disaster on
a3 I'm sorry so here I am what to do is
695 is not really on the agenda so I'm
going to do it I'm going to lie I want
to move the Queen and then loop the aid
get on to the d5 Queen g5 loop the edge
so that roopd tool becomes possible this
kind of thing
yeah but at night it's not doing amateur
[Music]
and even taking on d5 and putting this
on g4s grade yeah well cd8
yeah okay look do you wanna not easy to
break down there definitely not easy to
break down to eat
yeah maybe still play it and then then
see what to do
membership t4 doesn't look great
I mean that capture that line with the
capture and then put something on d4 I
know I could be in too little yeah it
has one one really really um key
advantage it's extremely one-sided yeah
I wonder if I should have played woop
the aid in the first place if I'm going
for that I don't want to trade route
like actually about okay hook the ADA's
it's rubbish ng8 I come to d2 so he
won't take on d8 yeah he has to take
with the cheap one I think it's better
than taking with the apron
so let's see for it is this a square
so I'm playing on this bishop being
better than this bishop yeah I just
recognize one thing but it's probably
not so important
if he goes rookie one he might play five
if I could be five myself he might have
a regrouping of the Bishop to c4 but
that is a really really long windows oh
yeah yeah I mean if you get the hell in
the meantime I have 55 and f5 on against
blue six a probably play rook g6 and
pick up that porn group d6 now that
should be fun yeah it's taking a while
okay so no tactic don't think so so I'm
going to do this I don't think that this
is actually doing anything good fun the
D found nothing happens and I will open
the position up with f5 try to bust
through under the F file now okay
so what is next would be six
hmm I don't want to trade Queens I mean
let's say age 60 takes this is still
pretty good but trading Queens was not
really what I wanted
I don't have a really great square it's
a bit weird Queen age for g3 yeah I mean
I'm not worried too much about g3 but it
feels like a retreat retreat feels a bit
passive okay I didn't want to do this
originally but it is okay I mean I get a
5 in next and this looks pretty bad
maybe you just plays like g4 I like a
full-scale passive defense
that group I play anyway I don't really
need to think twice them and he actually
has to take otherwise I take you form
and everything collapses already if you
take sit in that play before immediately
by the way what is why it's more I don't
need to I can just recapture and Andy
for next
well that already is really really awful
what what to see how is he defending
here we should be to e4 of the look okay
look can maybe go to g3 now you can go
to g3
in 43 amazing so let's bring the king to
have sixth order to allow this option
it's one advantage of blacks position I
can easily use the King like II for King
f6 King e5 and so on
yeah it's not easy and for white give
them some advices tough age three and
something to try to invade
she doesn't really do much yeah I was
thinking okay Jay it is simplest but if
I go g-form no gauge for I still play
along
yeah I wonder if I should go g4 and then
look age 81 if this is too lame
it is really a bit lame
[Music]
we should age hi this is helpful for me
yeah okay so what did I wanted to get
slightly more see verbal version of g4
and yeah I think I'm getting it
look h4s giving the rook with very
little squares if I go for then Bishop
h6 is going to be a threat okay so
look aged eight from the age three and
doesn't do much
and you for waiting for many yeah let's
go inform okay because Group g3 that you
gets really short so yes so he goes back
and now if I go look age eight
I'm taking the pawn and Kim Ji Won - III
and white is falling apart and what is
he playing not kim jiwon age three drops
upon
you know that looks that looks very good
kim jiwon III will then stuff
[Music]
don't see a good alternative for wider
okay so I think I'll take
we have a director taking plenty look h8
and invade or just look on the second
ring my king can also join even though F
4 and F 3 years am also looking quite
strong
yeah three looks krytus from the pawn
lens on f3 east when we are talking
about checkmate
yeah there's no defense it's no defense
to that Kim G - I go eight the AIT
resides that's probably maybe you can
avoid mate but sit it really looks looks
pretty bad okay is so let's have a look
sometimes it does it automatically
sometimes it's I don't know okay so we
get your little key points here by
transposition and proxy one yeah this is
a normal move of course take bishop c6
is looking sensible should have three
the engine valve left 23 for a moment
oh my every second loss looks high hey
did I really make a big mistake in this
game I would be surprising it didn't
feel like there was so much going on
technically okay now it goes down then
yeah Queen d3 the engineer initially
liked a lot but this is a normal normal
game okay Bishop a3 I'm not a huge fan
of this because it's just seven fairly
passive piece down and a form yeah that
puts more pawns on light squares I think
this is a strategic the strategic
mistake that potentially yeah makes this
bishop extremely bad yeah decided to uh
keep the song ya know Bishop c5 is the
kind of move I'd rather give up a pod
went and playing that but okay he took
it there now there are a couple of
options also just taking and e6
the engine subjects but I didn't want to
trade Queens all that all that quickly
it sounds like I have some chances on
the dark squares and now I'm down to
something like 20 which is a fairly
normal value for my rapid games it seems
so big takes we should reform yeah to
give up the bishop pay a bit we get a
position which is extremely one-sided
only black can do something here yeah
and now I can keep the Queen's on but I
mean ultimately through this h6 move
firm was very very a paid off losses in
the game but in general I wasn't sure
about it maybe this isn't very good Jim
and fight will come it is a definite
mistaken oh yeah he for was impossible
huh yeah I briefly considered this but
didn't fully didn't fully understand I
mean okay this is just goods as well but
if one looks a bit more powerful I seen
so ya can just have a snowball here and
now g4 was better than king g6 said
really bad
this should h5 and this should be true
now the King g6 also keeps an advantage
okay it seems like g4 is better yeah I
kind of agree because I mean later I saw
that g4 at the UK DM and he cannot go
here because after you find this is
strapped Lucas to stretch he went to
this one yeah you should go back to g3
which is not a lot of fun but we can
look at the line of suckers in g3 it's
nice answer Lucas again trapped the
middle of the port yeah so in the game
we have the situation and T g3 is maybe
a bit tougher but it's really not a
position you can play during ff3 route
h8 and made and yeah it's probably not
defensible
I mean even the mate is probably hard to
defend against the engine gives like -7
probably that is climbing if you give it
more time ok guys thanks for watching